well first of all thank you so much to
the organizers hopefully are going to
come for this wonderful conference so
much who was amazing and so the the talk
that i'm going to give today is going to
be joint work with darryl hoy who is now
postdoc in maryland and Vasilisa CONUS
who is on the market and who is opposed
aachen microsoft research and so this
project really started with me kind of
not knowing a lot about a GT a few years
back and I heard about this wonderful
concept of the price of anarchy and it
seems really magical to an economist
that it seems to be solving really
really complicated problems and so my
first thought was well what can we do
with it in order to aid inference and
essentially this project was was was all
started from from the very simple point
and I think that it he kind of led to
from from my perspective deeper
understanding for us of what the price
of Anarchy could be so first of all let
me just kind of give you a little bit of
a background in terms of how a
structural economist is thinking about
empirical modeling and I think Susan
aithe on the first day of the conference
kind of gave this hip the the hint of
the idea how this how this approach is
going but just just to kind of to put
you on this m and and and kind of in the
same framework so our goal is is really
going to be the goal of designing a
better system having the observations
from the current system and so we we
want to use the data and we want to use
the data in order to make informed
decision of how to design a new system
and the system is going to involve some
strategically competing agents and so
first of all in order to make any
predictions and in that environment
we're going to have to make a stand that
while the agents are responding and we
actually can model how they're
responding to the system and to each
other so we're going to have a model and
in most cases this is going to be a
model of the game and so when we want to
make a prediction in such an environment
and our only kind of our only framework
that we can use in this case is going to
be the framework of building the model
and trying to use that model to generate
those predictions other than rather than
maybe trying to run a regression and
trying to extrapolate somewhere and so
the the reason why the standard
regression approach is not going to work
is because the new the newly designed
system is has never been observed we
don't have that state of the world so
prediction is only going to be possible
when we go after the primitives of the
model so the parameters of the model
could be the preferences of the agents
there could be some kind of equilibrium
selection mechanism so those are going
to be the primitive components of the
game and so today I'm going to focus on
the auction design and and and most of
the applications i'm going to be talking
about are going to be the applications
to the sponsored search options on
microsoft's bing platform so so
basically just just to kind of you to to
sum up the mindset is we want to make
counterfactual predictions we want to
predict the system that we never
observed the only way for us to do that
using the current data is to have a
model of how the agents behave and to
recover the parameters of the model the
primitives of model the preferences of
the players participating in the game in
order to simulate what's going to happen
in your system aka the new equilibrium
so the question of counterfactual
prediction are usually the question of
looking at some concrete some concrete
mechanism to which we're going to
compare the current mechanism and say
something about that mechanism so we
want to say what are going to be in the
current circumstances what are going to
be the parameters of the optimal
mechanism another also very popular
concept is going to be trying to figure
out what's going to be the direction of
improvement of the current meh control
so war what are going to be the changes
of parameters such as say the reserve
price and the auction whether we're
going to raise it or lower it in order
to in order to improve the prop
edges of the mechanism and so of course
in in in large industrial systems we
want the solution to this to this
problem to actually satisfy the standard
condition so that we can actually deploy
it in the industrial scale so we want
the solution to be computationally
efficient we wanted to be scalable and
preferably we also want to make it
robust to modeling assumption so we
don't as much as we like a we meaning
economists as much as we like taking a
stand on a particular model and trying
to squeeze as much out of it model we
want to be somewhat more flexible in
terms of well if there are some
deviations from that model we don't want
our predictions to become completely
obsolete and become completely non
robust to that so let me just walk you
through one of such structural exercises
and this is going to be a very
simplified example but I think it's
going to it's going to really provide
the point that we why we why we need to
why we need to do a project like we did
in this particular case so basically
we're going to observe the data that are
going to be coming from the auction
system and the standard assumption is
going to be well the bidders are going
to be happy with their bids so they've
done their optimization and the system
is going to be assumed to be in
equilibrium meaning that the bidders are
going to the best responding to the
uncertainty of the bids of their
opponents and so the key observation
here is that if the system is truly in
equilibrium then we actually are
observing that equilibrium distribution
of uncertainty so now in order to model
what the agents is what the agent is
doing is we just need to take that
empirical distribution from the data and
in that empirical distribution we're
going to compute what's going to be the
best responding bid to the distribution
and that's going to give us a clear idea
with what the what the preferences of
the agents are if we have the model of
the preferences so basically given the
bid distribution we're going to solve
for the optional bit strategy we're
going to then invert the [ __ ] strategy
in order to find the parameters the
preference parameters such that make the
currently observed bid of this bitter
optional so that's that's the
you the kind of very you know simplified
version of what's done in the structural
inference and and so this approach is
very very dominant in the structural in
the inference and so the key features
that the economist's are trying to
accomplish while estimating that model
is first of all we need to make sure
that the model is identified meaning
that if we have a distribution of the
data there's going to be a unique set of
primitives that we're going to be able
to recover from the data so that's very
important because if there are multiple
multiple sets of primitives most
standard models are actually going to be
in trouble i'm going to show you moving
forward how we can relax that but in
principle we we are really really
worried about identification so then
once we made sure that the model that
we've specified is going to be
identified we're going to use the data
in further those primitives and then use
those primitives in order to make those
counterfactual predictions so we're
going to compute the new equilibrium in
the new system using the parameters of
preferences that we've recovered and so
right off the bat we're going to
actually face quite a few challenges so
first of all and and and i think susan
80 again she's been talking about it so
most economists take a real strong stand
on what the the actual model is going to
be so we're trying to squeeze as much as
we can from the data so most of the
models are going to be exactly
identified so there's going to be no
parameters that are going to allow us to
test the models in a meaningful way so
it's really hard for us to get a
variation that's going to say that well
we actually truly believe that this are
the agents preference so there's going
to be some inversion from the bids to
the values and then we're not going to
know whether this inversion is robust to
say the assumption of the utility this
is actually going to also leading to to
the problems with inference meaning that
well in in in in this case where we're
not sure whether this is the correct
model local deviations from that bottle
can actually generate pretty large
deviations in the estimates of the
primitives and then if now we're
thinking about using those Prem
tips to compute new counterfactual
equilibria in the in the new system well
we're going to that error is going to
propagate and that's going to generative
and throw the problems in in in that
projected in those predictions for the
new system so let me just again proceed
with a very simple example of an auction
and I'm going to consider the first
price auction with an exogenous
allocation rule so this is going to be
as simple as it gets so we're going to
look at the utility of the bitter in
this auction the allocation rule is
going to be X so each quantile in the
bid distribution is going to be
allocated with probability X the bitter
is going to collect the surplus which is
going to be value minus the bitter this
bitter so this is the first price
auction so the we have the allocation
rule which is exogenous it's a it's
allocating quantiles of the of the bed
distribution we're going to assume that
everything is going to be nice so this
is this is just again for simplicity so
there's going to be a mapping from the
quantile space to the space of bits
that's going to generate the quantile
function of the bid distribution we're
going to denote it be of q and under
some additional yeah a symmetric and a
all using yes yes yes yes so everything
is symmetric as simple as it gets I just
I want to abstract away from any
problems or complications so this is
just plain vanilla so excuse me xq
it'sit's exogenous let's just say that
it so it's not even related to be q I'm
just going to give you what the
allocation is so again this is done for
just to make it as kind of transparent
as fall so in in real auctions it's
going to be a function of BQ and it's
going to be even more complicated than
if excuse exogenous you don't need to
maximize visible potatoes sure sure but
I'm just trying to again at like this is
because there is a beep I mean xqz
because I what I says it's easy we're
talking about all the bidders together
excuse a function of the cube but if the
excuse XO didn't but I think he's using
a technology it's this is just this is
just an illustration I'm not this is not
going to be the core of the stock so
this is just an illustration don't don't
yell at me just yet so so let me so let
me just then write down the first order
condition for for the bitter in this
case and and the first order condition
is going to be to fairly simple again
exogenous allocation rule there is no
subscript I everything is super
symmetric so we we're going to have the
first order condition that's going to be
relating the quantile function of the
value distribution and the quantile
function of the bid distribution and the
unfortunate thing here is that there's
going to be the derivative of the
quantile function of the bid
distribution so that's going to be
really problematic in the sense that
we're going to have to infer that object
so on on the inference side though it
seems well it seems pretty good because
now we have this equation on the left
hand side this is the object that we
don't know and we don't observe and we
want to infer from the data on the right
hand side it seems that we have a
combination of objects so that we can
potentially infer from the data so the
bid distribution is observed in the data
the derivative of the bid distribution
is can be observed in the data so what
economists do is that they put hats
everywhere wants to have an equation
like that so hats meaning that we're
going to replace each object that we
that we have here with the object that
we observed from the data so this is the
empirical analog of that object that
gives us the estimator for the
primitives of the model which in this
case is going to be the value
distribution so now once we have the
value distribution we seem to be
completely kind of opening our path to
simulate what's happening in any kind of
actual auction so once we have the value
distribution in this auction we can
simulate what's happening in all pay
auction whatever auction would prefer so
now if we if we think about the
inference so the two objects that we
need to infer here given that the
allocation rule is exogenous is going to
be the quantile function the bid
distribution and its derivative so the
quantile function of the vid
distribution is in
in the standard way that's a that's just
a water statistics or CDF whatever you
prefer the derivative is going to be
significantly more problematic so the
inference of derivatives is in general
pretty bad and so let's just say that
the bid distribution is exponential so
in this case the the derivative for the
quantile function of the distribution
essentially inversely proportional to
the density so if we're now going to
compute the variance of this object when
the distribution of bids is exponential
then we're computing something that's
going to be an integral 1 over the
density so this integral is going to be
clearly diverging so this means that in
in in in fairly generic settings we
actually got an object that doesn't have
the finite second moment so now we're
trying to do some nations or or some
some kind of factual swear basically
dealing with the objects that are going
to be well first of all this means that
this object is going to be really
sensitive to the tail behavior of the
vid distribution and second so if we're
going to make some some local deviations
and by local deviations I'm going to
consider just small change in the tail
of the distribution the properties the
statistical properties of the object
that we're inferring which is the daily
distribution are going to be drastically
changing so let me just give you
something more formal so yeah it turns
out that we actually have a theorem
which is going to say that if we're
going to try to measure the performance
of a counterfactual for instance this is
going to be the revenues of the
counterfactual mechanism we're going to
find two distributions of bids which are
going to be close and then finish the
norm and and here as you can see what's
happening is that what's going to matter
the most is going to be the tail of the
distribution so if the distribution say
has unbounded support the the difference
in the Infinity norm can be very tiny
but if it's if it's way in the TL that's
going to matter the most from the
perspective of the subject so i can
actually generate two distributions that
are going to be close but they're going
to be generating drastically different
outcomes so this actually cannot be
fixed even if we have a bounded support
so this is a non generic problem if we
have bounded support and the density can
be kind
dropping off very quickly towards the
end of the support we're going to have
exactly the same problem so how do we
solve this problem well it turns out
that this problem has been thought about
both in economics and in computer
science and statistics specifically
image processing and the idea is going
to be to basically try to lump all of
the distributions that are going to be
closed so so now instead of working with
a single prediction for the
counterfactual revenue we're going to
work with a set of predictions that are
going to be generated by all of the
densities that we consider to be closed
and so well now knock the next question
is going to be can we somehow as you can
see this is a very simple situation
where we don't even need to compute
anything to do that inversion if we need
to compute something this is going to be
really difficult because now we're going
to have to compute this object for any
instance of potential bid distribution
within some range that we're considering
close and that's going to be a very
computationally expensive problem are
you assuming implicitly because you said
that the estimating the business
division is easy the right function P of
q ases is embraced that makes it that
way similar to lease the assumption
right yes so it's it I so what I should
have said estimation of BF q is easy air
so it's it's still we're still going to
have issues with it but it's just it's
just easier so BF q is going to be
estimate like you can estimate be of Q
as an order statistic at q
like there are contents in values and
contents and kids right it's not good to
me that page should we order the same as
I think it's different I think the point
is that even if you make all those
assumptions you still have this problem
this nicely precisely yes yep so in your
case things are going to be even more
difficult so so the point is is that
well it's clear that even in the
simplest case we need to work with the
sets and so the next question is what to
do with this so working with sets and
and so this is yeah which is it can you
can you accomplish something similar to
what you're describing by laser eyes
know and and that's so that's another
theorem so this is a kind of completely
different branch of research that I'm
doing so there's there's another theorem
that we can prove is that if everything
is determined by the tail behavior i can
always kind of adversarial a screw here
so if you're trying to bend windsor eyes
it then i can always choose the tails
that are going to be misbehavin beyond
so this this is this is actually the
very general class of problems that have
been considered in economics and now
very popular and and and this is this is
what's called the the partial SAT
identification literature this
literature was started by Chuck manski
at Northwestern and the basic idea of
saturda fication is actually very simple
so this is kind of a very plain plain
vanilla introduction and feel free to
exit the room if you if you if you feel
that this is just simple and offensive
so basically we're thinking about the
survey non-response and what we want to
estimate ultimately is going to be some
expectation of a statistic so suppose
that it's income and the problem that we
have here is we're going to send this
surveys to individuals and some
individuals are going to respond to the
survey and they're going to report their
income and let's just assume that there
is no strategic problems there etc etc
let's just say that every business
reports are not reports so the issue
that we're going to have there is that
not everybody is going to send us back
the surveys and what's also going to be
even more complicated is that the the
survey response is probably going to be
correlated with the value that we're
trying to measure so let's assume that
the variable that we're trying to
compute the expectation of has a bounded
support and we know the up
lower bounds of the support then manski
suggestion to this problem was the
following well given that we don't have
any extra information regarding how this
service response is occurring unless we
have a model about it then the only
thing we know is going to be the
probability of a particular person
responding at a particular person not
responding well maybe we have some other
variables we can do we can condition on
but then the simplest setup that's the
only thing we have and so then what we
need to do is we need to embrace that
the best that we can do for the part of
the distribution that we never observe
so this is the conditional expectation
of the outcome variable for people who
did not respond to survey the only thing
we know for this thing is well that it's
bounded between the upper and lower
bound so as a result our prediction for
the expectation is going to be an
interval where the lower part of the
interval is going to be replacing that
conditional expectation with the lower
bound of the support of Y and the upper
bound is going to be replacing that
variable with with the upper bound of
the support for y so this is what's
going to be called the identified set
for the expectation of Y so the
literature unidentified sets has
proliferated far into it again theory
and people have been trying to use it in
order to infer sets of preferences
especially in the games that are
so-called incomplete in the sense that
they can have multiple equilibria or the
there is there is some issues with
rationalities of flares the general
framework for partial asset
identification in game theoretical
structural models is going to include
the inference for a vector of parameters
which could be functions in principle so
that those don't have to be finite
dimensional parameters and what we're
going to look at is going to be the
distribution of the data so we're going
to assume that we have infinite access
to the data generation process so in
principle we can just observe this
entire distribution of the data there's
also going to be an unobservable
component that's going to be
characterizing something like
unobservable component of the
preferences so so this is going to be
some random noise so then the model is
going to be formulated as a set of
equalities and inequalities
just for the so called conditional
moment so this this could be for
instance the deviation and equalities
and games so then the the goal here is
going to be looking at the distribution
of the data which is going to be
representing the distribution of this
terrible why we're going to try to find
the set of parameters that are going to
be solving the set of parameters theta
that are going to be solving this
population system of equations and
inequalities so there's going to be some
set which is going to be called theta
theta I and it's going to be called the
identified set that's going to be
containing the parameters that could
have generated the data so there's going
to be the whole set of parameters that
are going to be consistent or compatible
with the model that generates this
equality and inequalities and the data
which is going to be this distribution
of Y I sorry makes sense okay robust
method of moments basically this is yes
yes well you can you but yes you can
call it that way but so there is no
there's no inference here so far so this
is all about just what is the structure
of this data so the if we think about
the properties of the identified set so
the identified set is going to be now
producing the set of primitives of the
game so now if we think about say an
auction game this is going to be the set
of values so just a set of distributions
of values that are compatible with the
observable data distribution and say the
the equilibrium conditions on the
utilities of players and in some cases
this data is going to be the object of
interest and if you look at most
structural papers in economics this is
this is essentially what people are
focusing on is what is going to be the
set of parameters that are going to be
consistent with the data however in in
most practical applications at least the
applications I've encounter with the the
ultimate goal is really going to be the
goal of counterfactual inference so this
is going to be something like the
welfare or revenues of the
counterfactual mechanism and the values
themselves there well maybe they're in
some cases that are important but
they're not that important and so if we
if we now think about kind of going
through the path of inferring the
identified set for the parameters of the
model
and then projecting that on some very
small subspace it seems that there's a
lot of wastes at work there so we kind
of didn't need to compute that that said
originally so the so this is this is
something that I mentioned before so I'm
game theoretical settings the intraday
object of interest is going to be
something like welfare or or revenue of
the of some optimal mechanism and so the
kind of the approach that we're going to
pursue if we're going to recover this
identified set and projected is going to
be difficult and especially this is
going to be difficult when we try to
embed it into counterfactuals because
now imagine that we have a set of
possible values for all of the players
so each point of the set will need to
correspond to some kind of equilibrium
so we'll need to compute an equilibrium
for each point of the super multi
dimensional set that we've generated for
all of the players and then that's going
to be even harder if they're going to be
issues with using some nice best
responses so if there's going to be
deviation from the opto best response
things are going to be very difficult so
what we want to try to do is we want to
try to bypass somehow this entire
process of inferring this data I and
then projecting it and replacing it with
something nice or even though we're
going to generate potentially something
larger than what we're going to get if
we get the status set here and so the
idea here is going to be to maybe try to
reinterpret the idea of the price of the
enter key by the first introduced by the
co to payson papadimitriou so if that
that probably should be familiar to all
of this audience so basically we're
looking at the worst-case ratio of in
our case we're looking at the worst-case
ratio of the welfare of the the optimal
auction and the end the auction that
we're currently running on the data and
there exists a really nice very
theoretical attractive methods of
evaluating the price of the enter key
there are based on of just unilateral
deviations of players so this are kind
of very computationally straightforward
exercises and so this is found theoretic
Lee useful and
the price of anarchy's is this is very
nice properties for for a lot of
familiar games and in simulations and at
least in my experience we're actually
finding something a lot better when
we're looking with concrete
distributions and concrete mechanisms so
if we if we think about and so this is
my own interpretation so if somebody
disagrees with that please say something
so my own interpretation is that
basically if we if we're looking at the
kind of classical price of anarchy
essentially the classical price of
anarchy is a property of the mechanism
so we're looking at all possible values
and then we're trying to see what are
the properties of this mechanism over
all possible values as opposed to say
the optimal mechanism now if we think
about kind of trying to somehow bland it
with reality if we if we're trying to
combine it with the knowledge that we
have well not all of the value
realizations are going to be equally
probable they're going to be realized
with equal probability and so now what
we what we want to try to do is we want
to try to somehow infer the idea of what
values are going to be a most realistic
by observing how the bitters play so if
the bitters play low maybe there are
values hello if they if they bit high
there may be their values are high
that's informative so now what we want
to do is we want to somehow restrict the
price of Anarchy making it the worst
case scenario under the constraint that
the distribution that we observe is
compatible with the observable place of
the players that we observe in the data
so this is what we call the empirical
price of anarchy and in this case this
is going to be now a combined property
of the mechanism and the distribution of
values so basically if we are able to
solve this problem we're going to also
say something about the primitives about
the primitives of the game which is that
which are going to be the values of
players and this is also going to be
very closely related to the notion of
identified set and if we're looking at
the welfare this is going to be say the
identified set for
are the optimal counterfactual welfare
because we never run that the optimal
mechanism here we only run the mechanism
that we do run yeah so do you mean that
this is off of the one distribution or
do you think that the are you saying
that this is the worst case over all of
the possible distributions that are
still consistent with the data yes yes
the second one so this is the this is
all possible distribution that are
consistent with the data yes get the
same answer if I did this identified set
stuff you were talking about and then
looked over all those distributions and
found the worst case price like the
worst case ratio in that set uh well
it's not going to be quite so we we
don't have universal tightness results
so it's going to be contained and i'll
show you the picture yeah i'll show you
the picture how much time don't have
just little over 10 minutes okay x okay
you have like a concrete-like set of
institutions it can't be one of these
and it cannot be something else or if
you have some sort of distribution that
okay it could be something else too but
with low probability so we're we're in
in this work we're not going to give you
the so we're working exactly on that
particular question so in in in
particular examples we can we can give
you those distributions what I'm going
to kind of give here is going to be more
like what is the recipe for computing
the optimum given the data so I'm not
going to tell you what what exactly is
violated your definition of in terms of
price of anarchy because if you have
those tales those don't go away when you
take the worst case so what by the tales
you mean that could be but probably on I
don't think that they're going to do
this is so I don't think that they're
going away but so how's the positive
problematic so if you have a set of
distributions yes so it would be one of
those and it can't be anything else we
take the worst case all of that I
understand how this would be one of the
five friends if you don't have that
because of data you know you could have
said you could have basically any
distribution with some probability then
I don't understand I've no no so I
that's not what I said so I said that
those distributions probably exist I
just I'm not going to be able to the
distributions that are definitely not
consistent with the data so the
distribution definitely exists and they
definitely existing you compute some
expectations of some qualities yes I
mean you know with some time probability
coefficient crazy this division of those
it's right I think what Thomas is asking
is it should be a weighted sum or
something like that like you know you
are you know you know every possible
distribution explains that data with
some power and you should be doing some
weighted so you're you're doing that
waiting already because what you're
observing is going to be the
distribution of actions so your
distribution of actions is already a
mixture distribution and that mixture
contains all possible things that that
could have been generating the data so
fusion everyone is having is everything
is at least in principle consistent with
the data but maybe with a vanishingly
small probability unless you set a
confidence level yes you haven't ruled
out anything and hence your price of
Anarchy should be the same as the
theoretical bath sure so so basically I
mean what I'm talking about here is a
population object up to this point there
is no data so let's assume that we just
know the distribution of the data we
just know that is so in that case is
just a single distribution there is no
there is no noise there yes right so
there's no there's no data noise here
whatsoever
you have a huge amount of data so
everything that could be concurrently
some probability is encouraged for sure
yes something that's no welcome no
matter how many right exactly yes
exactly exactly and so I and then I mean
at the end of the day we're going to
work with an empirical distribution and
we know how quickly the empirical
distributions are going to converge the
true one so that's going to determine
our error bounds so when yes so in the
end we're going to plug those empirical
distributions in and just produce the
what's going to be the price of in
turkey so given that I'm running out of
time I'm going to skip the pictures and
so the bulk of the stock was is going to
be about position options that will
specifically generalized second price
options the Bing runs and so this are
the cliq weighted generalized score
waited generalized second price auction
they run in continuous time meaning that
there's going to be a lot of uncertainty
that's going to be introduced by the
user traffic each query is going to be
score weighted so the scores are going
to be generated for all of the bidders
and given that the bidders are not able
to respond to the queries in in real
time they're going to be responding to
expectations of queries and so in each
query the scores are going to be
regenerated generating this very smooth
option so at the end of the day things
are going to be smooth out so there's
not going to be step functions like in
standard generalized second price
options so this is going to be an
expectation of the generalized second
second price auction where the
expectation is going to be taken with
respect to the realizations of the score
uncertainty so now if we think about the
decision of the player in this case the
decision of the player is going to be to
maximize the utility from quick so
there's going to be a value per click
which is going to be mapped maximum x
the expected quantity of clicks that
this bitter is going to receive and a
given in the given query which is going
to be now a smooth function of bids
minus the expected cost and that the
expected cost is again going to be some
smooth function of bid because we're
taking expectation over high uncertainty
distributions so then if we if we think
about implementation of full information
that
librium in this case now given the
competing bids who are going to be able
to compute those smooth functions we're
going to be just able to simulate them
very very quickly and then as how Varian
was selling yesterday what we need to do
then is we need to take the derivative
of the cost and and we're going to get
the value equals marginal cost very
simple seems very straightforward the
problems that are going to arise
immediately as you go to the data well
first of all in order for this model to
work we need the marginal cost to be
monotone and in a lot of the queers it's
clearly not so that approach of equation
values marginal cost is going to break
down in three seconds and most squares
even in Google I'm sure the second thing
is that there is a the click yeah not
even monotone in some queries sometimes
it happens yes yes it happens yeah so
the second thing that's going to happen
is that the the click function is going
to have going to have flat spots and
especially this is going to be the case
for the top bidders because when we have
Amazon which dominates everywhere we're
never going to see anybody about Amazon
the the cost of the click function is
going to be well essentially flat we're
dividing by something that's equal to
zero we're going to get infinite value
so there's there's not going to be any
value in the marginal cost inference and
then there's going to be a bunch of
other things such as a drifting
distribution of uncertainty deviation
from the optimal best response a lot of
the bidders are actually not changing
their bid that frequently so we get we
get really large deviation from the from
from kind of the standard equilibrium
model and so in this context partial
identification seems to be a natural
next step but then there's going to be a
problem because now we're going to have
to recover those large sets of values
that we're going to have to project on
the set of bits and the approach that
we're going to take is going to be this
idea of using the distribution of the
data in order to provide the balance by
passing the computation of those
alternative outcomes so here is
the definition that we're going to use
so this is going to be the the
definition of the empirical price of
anarchy so we're going to have the
distribution of uncertainty which we are
going to which we're going to subscribe
by theta and we're going to compare the
welfare of the optimal action with the
welfare of the option that we actually
are running and we're going to take the
soup over all possible distribution over
all possible realizations of the Alice
in the strategies within some given
class such that the distribution of the
bids that we're actual observing so
again this is the true distribution that
we're observing is going to be exactly
this FB so this is this is exactly what
we know so the what turns out to be a
useful approach is going to be the
approach of so-called revenue covering
so it turns out that this price of
Anarchy object is going to be able to
we're going to be able to recover it
independently without computing this
this this constrained optimization
problem where instead we're going to be
able to provide an upper bound for this
object using using this approach so
let's define the thresholds and the
thresholds are going to be defined by
the so called the inverse price per
click function so this is going to be
the price per click that I'm going to
have to pay in order to receive exactly
Z clicks so this everything is an
expectation here and then I'm going to
compute the the average price per click
as essential an integral so if I'm being
the average price per click for every
click batch that I'm getting how much in
total I'm going to have to pay so why so
what the next step is going to be to
define the revenue covering so we're
going to say that the strategy profile
of the auction is new revenue covered
when the revenue of the auction is going
to be multiplied by the spectrum you is
going to be greater for any allocations
that we're going to impose that the
sound of those thresholds across the
bidders and so then the auction is going
to be in general new revenue covered for
any strategy profile this inequality is
going to hold so why is why is this
object of interest well it's of interest
first of all because we can establish
this and
quality so this is the sum of utility
and the weighted threshold is going to
be bounded from above by some weighted
welfare that are going to that is going
to be prescribed to this bitter so this
is the quantity of clicks times the
value which is the total welfare that's
generated for this for this bitter it
turns out that the price of anarchy is
going to be bounded from above by this
function of the MU the the corresponding
revenue covering parameter so why is
this exciting so the revenue covering
parameter is the parameter that's
essentially determined by the revenue
that we directly observe in the data and
by these thresholds that we can compute
from the data so these are the functions
that are characterizing the price per
click so our strategy to then bound the
price of Anarchy from above is going to
be to use a version of this formula
we're going to compute the muse so views
are now functions of simple low
dimensional objects that are directly
observable in the data having them you
we're going to be able to bound the
price of anarchy and as a result we're
going to be able to bound the welfare
ratio for the observable distributions
of bids well so here is the relationship
that I wanted to show you so basically
now we have kind of multiple levels of
things that are happening in this
environment first of all price of
anarchy is not going to be imposing any
restriction on the distributions of a
lease because it's it's just the you
know it's it's a it's a supreme over
over all possible distributions of Valis
now we have the identified set that
corresponds to the the bound on the
welfare that we're going to generate
over all possible values that are
consistent with the data and the
consistent with a particular concept of
equilibrium that we're working within
the data then we're going to have the
empirical price of Anarchy which is
going to so in some cases going to be
tight is going to coincide with the
identified set but in general is going
to be larger because it may be not
ordering some of those inequalities that
are going to be now binding for multiple
bidders at the same time because the pie
set price of anarchy is working with
unilateral deviations and then we have
the revenue covering bound that I just
showed you that
revenue covering bound is going to be
larger slightly then the price of an arc
is going to be bounding the price of
energy from above but it's but it's
definitely going to be containing the
identified set so given that I'm
completely running out of time I'm just
going to show you some nice pictures so
this is a week so we worked with 11
keywords on being this are the actual
relationships between the the
allocations and the price per clicks
using this price per clicks price per
click curves we can compute the
threshold so this is the actual
thresholds that we compute and then use
in our approach and so there's a lot of
numbers the numbers to look at and this
is the inverse price of Anarchy so this
is the price of Anarchy that we compute
using our formula and you can see that
in principle for most of the keywords
we're looking at the price of anarchy is
actually pretty good there's a couple of
keywords that are that are clearly
problematic and this is the keywords
that are really monopolized we actually
have a few refinements of the formula
that we have in principle we can use
some other structures within within the
within the game in order to tighten the
bound even further and that gives us a
slightly better values for the price of
Anarchy you can see that we're getting
much closer to 1 in this case so given
that I'm completely out of time I try to
provide a link but when the literature
on partial identification in car metrics
and the results from the algorithm game
theory and it turns out that the the
concept of the price of Anarchy applied
to data is providing useful bounds and
in application to real data gives a way
of diagnostic of a particular auction
mechanism so essentially this gives us a
very cheap way of seeing whether the
current mechanism that we're running is
deviating from the optimum for the given
set of realizations of the early
distributions that are plausible using
our data and the application seems to be
possible to a lot of other markets with
the same ease
tell us a couple of questions yeah you
mentioned the whiteness to designing I
turn to my friends just for the carbon
package and the optimum so the so I
think it is possible so in in the
current framework they kind of i'm going
to offer you a very unpleasant solution
of just using the triangle inequality
and which is not going to be very nice
and attractive it seems that it's
possible to narrow down the notion of
the price of anarchic is some kind of
like an arbitrary welfare ratio i'm not
sure that it's always applying so it
applies to very simple games but I so I
think that there is a great promise
there so if well if we're able to
accomplish that then you know we solved
the problem of counterfactual inference
yeah so you showed us some EPO EPO a
bound what were the py bound for the
setting you look you oh so this is the
generalized second price auction so the
the revenue covering doesn't even you
know they're not revenue covered so
that's the beauty is that so in our case
we don't need to worry about whether
their revenue covered or not I'm sorry I
kind of skepta we actually just compute
the actual empirical revenue covering
parameter as far as i know i am not sure
actually I don't think so but so it's
score way too generalized second price
auction so i'm not sure somebody
computed yeah so this first column of
numbers that that's for efficiency right
yes so so this one this they're all for
efficiency so that well this is the this
is the ratio of the threshold so this is
this is mu essentially on the free for
so that that means about price of
anarchy it is like for yes yeah it makes
empirical price yep mm-hmm and you see
that that happens when there's keyboard
is one of the wise yeah I don't they
understand that because it seems to me
that if the key word is monetized and
somebody's the best guy it's easy to get
the efficiency that guy I can't escape
so so x is x is always a personality
high in those cases it's in that it
should be long what it's harder to
identify and you get more noise in the
identification piece basically or what
what's happening is that the the if if
you have a dominant bitter then this
dominant bitter is going to
significantly shape their bid and I mean
it could be it could be yes so it's that
what's that he shaves a lot of the other
guys shave almost none because they will
think about a single item auction
it's not monopolize let Thomas is right
it must be the identification issued
satiated it not instead well it's the
first price auction remember don't think
second present at this Nash equilibrium
right so it's full information Nash
equilibrium so I'm not going to shave my
dibs or the back shows I will shade it
but I'll still with me so I ok I'm is
that even if you shake your definition
of water politely that you're a winner
but here are we are you ready so and I
wasn't giving you the causal
interpretation of this numbers I just
that I just gave you a simple statement
of the fact so this is so we are
observing this and and I think that this
this search phrases are problematic just
because of the domination of the few
players but I'm not sure social duffer
what is it problematic for your
methodology this thomason is it appears
to be problematic for your methodology
all right so I don't think so you know
so I that I don't think so because so we
can just compute the welfare directly
right so we can we can use the we can
use the value equals the marginal cost
approach and I mean in that case let me
suggest
you